KARL-ANTHONY TOWNS.
SO IT'S TOWNS, THEN YOUNG, AND
THEN LUKE KENNARD.
>> HE HAS TO HAVE THE BEST ROUND
OF HIS SHOOTING LIFE RIGHT NOW,
REGGIE.
>> HE COULD PUT A LOT OF
PRESSURE.
>> LET'S SEE IF HE HAS A
28-ROUND, REG.
PUT A LOT OF PRESSURE.
>> I THINK 25 WILL WIN IT.
>> I THINK WE GO UP TO 28.
>> LET'S GO, BIG FELLA.
>> MONEY RACK IS IN THE MIDDLE,
BY THE WAY.
HE GOT THE NERVOUSNESS OUT OF
THE WAY.
HE IS MORE RELAXED.
HE LOOKS MORE CALM.
>> HE DOES.
>> HIS SPOT IS COMING UP.
GET HOT!
>> NOT BAD.
I JUST YELL.
SORRY.
>> MONEY RACK.
>> REMEMBER, HE MISSED BOTH OF
THOSE DEW BALLS THE FIRST TIME
OUT.
>> FIRST MISS ON THE MONEY RACK.
THREE OUT OF FOUR.
MAKE IT FOUR OUT OF FIVE.
OH, YEAH!
HE TOOK A DIFFERENT PATH THIS
TIME.
GET A RHYTHM.
>> WHOA!
LET'S GO!
>> IT'S A WRAP.
>> REG, I SAID 28, REG.
WE NEED 28!
>> WE'RE TALKING ABOUT 30.
>> SIX ARE AVAILABLE.
>> I'M GOING TO VEGAS!
>> TWO IN A ROW IN THE CORNER.
>> MONEY BALL!
>> 30.
31?
OH, MAN.
YOU CALLED IT.
>> OH, IT'S A WRAP.
>> OKAY.
THAT IS CALLED PRESSURE.
HE WANTED TO BE KNOWN AS THE
BEST BIG MAN SHOOTER EVER.
LOOK AT HIM.
HE IS DOING THE D-LO.
>> THIS IS HOW YOU BECOME KNOWN
AS THE BEST BIG MAN SHOOTER
EVER.
>> WHAT A START.
>> DO IT ON THE BIGGEST STAGE,
REG.
>> HE HAS SOME HITTERS BEHIND
HIM THOUGH.
>> HE DOES.
ICE TRAY BEHIND HIM.
KENNARD.
OH, YEAH.
>> HE REALLY GOT IT GOING ON
THAT SECOND RACK.
KENNARD SAYING, SLOW IT DOWN,
MAN!
SLOW IT DOWN.
KARL-ANTHONY TOWNS THERE.
ONLY TEN AVAILABLE IN THE
CORNER.
>> A WINNER.
>> LOOK AT K.A.T.
>> IN THIS IS THE YEAR OF THE
K.A.T.
>> THIS MEANS SOMETHING TO HIM.
>> THAT'S GREAT.
KARL-ANTHONY TOWNS!
HE HAS WON THE MTN DEW 3-POINT
CONTEST.
>> THAT'S GREAT.
>> OKAY, BIG FELLA.
BIG MEN REJOICE ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
>> DID YOU SEE THAT INTERVIEW HE
DID WITH STEPHANIE READY WITH
THE GUYS TALKING ABOUT, LOOK,
THERE IS NO PRESSURE.
40% ON THE SEASON FROM THREE.
I'M JUST GOING IN THIS TO WIN.
LET'S DO THIS.
>> HE SAID, CHECK MY RESUME.
>> RIGHT.
>> HIS FIRST APPEARANCE IN THE
THREE-POINT SHOOTING CONTEST.
KARL-ANTHONY TOWNS.
>> YES, SIR.
>> HE WINS THE MTN DEW 3-POINT
CONTEST.
MAN, THAT IS SOMETHING.
THAT IS GOING TO BE A MEMORY FOR
A LI